das ist nicht mehr kleinkram das muss
viel mehr passieren dass sie keine
kleinkriminellen
die alaba haben angefangen diese ganze
web zähler zu stürmen mit beschrieben
ein teufel und den platz um nach außen
man lässt sich einfach mit teufel ein
mein rücken helfer der kampf gegen die
organisierte kriminalität wird eine
daueraufgabe seien
[Musik]
vergebens jetzt intensiv
das schreckt aber nicht ab weiter die
geschäfte zu bauen die rappen über
drogen und so das ist ja super werden ja
dadurch zu markenbotschaftern für unsere
produkte und
du kannst deine mercedes gefahr und du
kannst eine shisha cafés und du kannst
das ganze geld waschen
[Musik]
weiter
sie akzeptieren unser system nicht wie
machen sich den staat zur beute diese
mentalität der rechtsstaat auf sylt es
tauchen immer wieder die gleichen namen
auf angefangen von abou chaker überall
sein bis hin zu ali khan und oma die
haben wirklich das gefühl das ist in
deutschland erlaubt was ihr machen es
wird unterstellt schaut her was wir
können alice im wunderland
[Musik]